wie ist denn da gerade der aktuelle
stand es gibt neue umfragen die
präsidenten haben alarmieren müssen und
die beziehen sich hauptsächlich auf die
auf seine performance während der
tv-debatte es ist ja kaum zu glauben
dass anfangen anfang dieser woche ein
ist das große tv duell in cleveland
statt gefunden hat über das niemand mehr
redet dennoch es wurden umfragen
durchgeführt ungefähr in diesem zeitraum
und hier ist da joe biden in den
umfragen davon gezogen laut einer
umfrage von nbc wolfsburg hat sich der
vorsprung von joe biden in dieser
nationalen umfrage fast verdoppelt auf
14 prozent das ist als reaktion auf die
auf das tv duell zu werten genau
umfragedaten über die jetzige
gesundheitskrise werden jetzt gerade
hergestellt man wird ja zehn oper der
präsident ob ihm das politisch hilft
diese einlieferung ins krankenhaus diese
dieses gesundheits drama ob ihr der
mitleidseffekt schlagend wird oder ob es
sei schade dass werden jetzt die
umfragen in den nächsten stunden und
tagen zeigen